are you a recent graduate with an
excellent skillset do you prosper in an
international work environment
are you motivated to help shape the
future of Europe the EU institutions
offer the opportunity to work on some of
the most pressing challenges we face as
a society we are currently looking for
talented graduates to meet these
challenges and to take on a broad range
of tasks in formulating and delivering
EU policies you will be part of diverse
teams dealing with topical issues such
as fighting climate change
managing migration or boosting economic
growth and creating jobs new members of
staff usually work in Brussels or
Luxembourg both lively capitals in the
heart of Europe to apply you need a
university degree of at least four years
of studies in any field knowledge of two
EU languages and EU citizenship episodes
equal opportunities policy ensures all
qualified candidates have a fair chance
for more detailed information please
visit graduates dot EU - careers dot EU
shaping Europe together
[Music]